mortal engines was directed by Kristian
rivers produced by Peter Jackson and is
about a young woman named Hester Shaw in
a post-apocalyptic world where cities
drive around on wheels some are larger
than others like London and they eat
smaller cities to help power their city
and Hester eventually teams up with a
guy named Tom both of them were wronged
by Hugo Weaving character named
Valentine to go after him and try to
stop a conspiracy
the trailers will have you believe that
this is Peter Jackson's next film that
he directed the marketing doesn't have
much confidence in its director in fact
there are actual people I know who talk
about movies for a living who legit
thought Peter Jackson directed this
movie it's bound to become one of those
Nightmare Before Christmas scenarios
like a lot of people think that a film
was directed by Tim Burton when it was
really Henry Selick
this film has so much going for it
behind the scenes and in front of the
camera it's a gorgeous looking film with
amazing visual effects production design
Kristian rivers was an uncredited
storyboard artist on most of Peter
Jackson's films he directed a small
feature which I've never seen or even
heard of according to his IMDB account
so this is his first gigantic film was
so much going on and it's gorgeous to
look at but it's pretty dull in every
other aspect
I wasn't invested in a single character
in this movie the character I understood
the most and cared about the most was
this kind of robot zombie thing they
refer to as their resurrected besides
had the rest of the characters are just
pieces that are shifted in and out of
frame to propel the plot along they try
to delve into the backstory of these
characters and they do but all of it
feels so familiar and so derivative of
other things this film owes its soul to
so many other better films Howl's Moving
Castle one of the biggest ones another
film by Miyazaki Castle on the sky or
the Mad Max films most recently it even
has a score by junkie XL which hits you
so hard in the early scenes that it
feels like you're watching the finale of
the movie even though it's the first 10
minutes mortal engines feels like the
third film in a trilogy like we've had
two films already that are leading to
this gigantic finale but there's no
films that have preceded this the
development isn't there
it feels like that's what should have
happened with this movie that we're
watching it's like it ignores all of
those usual things you you need in a
film so big with so many characters like
this it feels like we need so much more
story to understand the importance of
the events going on because the film
treats everything as so hyper serious
that you can't really have much fun with
it either
the attempts at humor usually fall
pretty flat and the gorgeous art
production and costume design and visual
effects are mostly wasted because you
just don't give a shit about what's
going on which is really unfortunate
because there's a lot of talent in this
movie I mean Fran Walsh and Peter
Jackson writing the screenplay this
should have been amazing even the ending
owes itself to another film which I
won't get into but it just feels like a
bunch of movies we've seen before
that we're better than this I'm gonna
give mortal engines a c-minus guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon I have
a lot of stuff to cover before Christmas
time you guys are the best as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]